good morning Hank it's Tuesday I've
always wanted a signature move this
started when I was in middle school and
susceptible to ludicrously
oversimplified ideas about social status
on account of not having any and
desperately wanting some anyway some
guru of that era wrote in some guide to
being cool that one of the keys was
nodding upward whenever you encountered
someone in a hallway or whatever rather
than nodding downward which was a sign
of like subservience so I tried to make
the up nod my signature move to tell my
peers that I was confident and powerful
which you know went about as well as you
would expect later I developed a new and
much worse signature move which I
hesitate to even tell you about but it
was this as a form of greeting my Chi
would be like hello there and that one
also surprisingly did not become for me
what the moonwalk was for Michael
Jackson or heel clicking is for the
Lucky Charms leprechaun and so I trudged
through life as a person without a
signature move Hank I've been thinking
about this recently because you're
currently signing 40,000 sheets of paper
that will be bound into your forthcoming
first novel an absolutely remarkable
thing which comes out September 25th and
is available for pre-order now and you
sent me 2,000 copies of these sign
sheets for me to add something to the
way that you have added your signature
move the Hank oarfish too many copies of
my books which I'm happy to do except I
don't have a hold on okay late-breaking
news the first review of heck's book has
just come out like literally minutes ago
and it's so great it's a star review
from Kirkus and it calls an absolutely
remarkable thing a fun contemporary
adventure that cares about who we are as
humans especially when faced with
remarkable events Green is clearly
interested in how social media moves the
needle on our culture and he uses
April's Fame choices and moral
quandaries to reflect on the rending of
social fabric Hank that is so good I am
so excited your book is so brilliant I
cannot wait for people to read it okay
back to the regularly scheduled video
right so I have these two thousand
sheets of paper from a book that just
got a really good review but I don't
have a signature move I mean even my
eight-year-old son has a signature move
the pokeball which he's put on several
of these sheets so first I thought that
since you have the Hank coefficient
organism might be appropriate but I
figured you know for me it should
probably be something microscopic so I
tried to make like uh I don't really
know what that is it's a little bit like
the Sun but also a little bit like a
bacterium and I thought I loved Hanks
book so much maybe I'll give it five
stars only to learn that I can't draw
stars then I thought well I'm better
with words so maybe I'll make a
figure with the speech bubble that says
Hanks book is great but that looks like
it was made by a five-year-old in the
end here is what I've settled on on
about half the copies I'm drawing what I
see when I think of spirals which is to
say as close as I can get to this
Raymond Pettibon painting which I wrote
about in Turtles all the way down
I figure that spirals even if I don't
want them to be my signature move sort
of are so that's about half of them and
then on the other half I'm writing dftba
in the infinite shadow created by the
Carl by the way that strikes me as an
extremely metaphorically resonant
infinite shadow I know that neither of
these moves is Hank or fish level
quality but it's the best I've got and
if you preorder a signed copy of Hanks
book you have a five percent chance of
getting one of those things and also a
one in 40,000 chance of getting this one
sheet that Hank forgot to sign so I
wrote a note and tried to recreate Hanks
signature on it
Hank congratulations on your book and
that amazing review months after first
reading it I still think about it all
the time and I really think it's a book
that might change the world for the
better there are links in the doobly-doo
below to order signed copies of an
absolutely remarkable thing I am gonna
go watch the World Cup and make some
spirals Hank I will see you on Friday